- Last year, Charli XCX
tweeted, "What is hyperpop?"
Comments ranged from full-blown
deconstructions of genre,
to, "It's just pop" to many
simply answering "You."
- [Arthur] Though the
microgenre-turned-online scene
has experienced many changes
over its short lifespan,
there's no one way to define hyperpop.
Ask anyone from the scene
and they'll give you a different answer.
Pop music is constantly evolving,
and hyperpop seems like
the next logical step.
- In this video, we're going
to dig into the question,
"What is hyperpop?" by
exploring its musical origin,
and at the end,
we're gonna make our own
hyperpop inspired track.
So make sure to stick around.
(upbeat pop music)
- Like most things on the Internet,
hyperpop has evolved
rapidly over the years.
Recently, its popularity has grown
from playlists on Spotify and Apple Music,
and many hyperpop tracks
have caught fire on TikTok.
♪ Feel so clean like a money machine ♪
- [Linda] Going viral,
I feel like is something
that also is linked to hyperpop in a way.
- Yeah. Oh yeah, definitely.
I feel like viral things
are typically things that just like,
people don't understand at first.
That quest to understand these things,
I think is like the funnest part about it.
It's like understand
this music and be like,
"All right, why did
someone ever make something
that sounds like this?
I hate it." And then
all of a sudden you're like...
- [Linda] Yeah.
- ... Wait this actually
slaps really hard.
- Yeah. I'm thinking about this.
I'm listening to this in the shower.
Why is this so catchy?
That's what happened to me
then I got TikTok recently
and I was like, whoa,
this is like the sound of a generation.
- So where did hyperpop come from?
Hyperpop's origins can be
traced back to the mid 2000s
with the rise of the
Nightcore scene on YouTube.
Nightcore is a genre that revolves around
increasing the pitch and
tempo of pre-existing songs
and is often paired with
anime visuals or cover art.
♪ Cause every time we touch ♪
♪ I feel this static ♪
♪ And every time we kiss ♪
♪ I reach for the sky ♪
- [Linda] According to Spotify
analyst, Glenn McDonald,
the term hyperpop started being used
in reference to the UK based,
PC Music collective in 2014,
which was founded by producer A.G Cook.
Just like many other new genres,
many critics did not respond
well to the fresh sound.
In the 2010s, PC Music and it's artists
such as Hannah Diamond,
Danny L. Harle,
Girlfriend Of The Year and Kane West
created innovative pop music
defined by its blend of perky melodies
and frenetic digital production.
(upbeat music)
♪ Beautiful ♪
♪ Baby when you look at me ♪
♪ You know that I'll be here forever ♪
- I think having really
heavy hitting drum samples
is really important and really like,
focusing on the sound design,
you know, having this
sort of like crystalline,
like it's sort of this balance
between these hyper like
shiny sounds and these super
distorted, messed up sounds.
- Do you feel like that
distortion is what differentiates
hyperpop from regular pop?
- I think that's definitely
one of the clearest things, I think.
From a technical
standpoint from, you know,
mixing and mastering,
like when I'm mastering
a hyperpop song,
I'm taking the limiter and I'm smashing it
because that's the sound.
(upbeat music)
- Many of the newer figures of hyperpop
have taken the exaggerated
eclectic elements,
laid down by PC music, and
combined them with hip hop,
like the sounds of cloud rap.
- SoundCloud has played a monumental role
in the birth and growth of hyperpop.
And it's given smaller hyperpop artists,
a place to share their
music with the world.
Artists Osquinn,
previously known as P4RKR,
SEBII
and Saturn,
are influenced by mid
2010's SoundCloud emo rap,
like Yung Lean
and more mainstream
artists like Playboi Carti.
Artists like DOLLYWOOD1,
BLACKWINTERWELLS and KID TRASH
are more focused on
heavily distorted 808s,
playful melodies and unnatural auto-tune,
creating a blend of rap, pop and EDM.
(mellow hyperpop music)
♪ I sit back and they all
look at me and laugh ♪
♪ That's not how I began ♪
- [Linda] Probably the
most influential figure
in the hyperpop scene is
Scottish producer, Sophie.
- She's in everything, all of
these songs that exist now,
there's like some piece
of her that is within it,
in this kind of like almost
like spiritual way for me.
And I think, yeah, Arca, you know,
it was always like queer and trans artists
who were at the forefront.
- Sophie was obsessed
with the way a bubble has an
ascending pitch when popped.
You can hear Sophie play
around with this sound
on tracks like "Lemonade".
♪ Candy boys c-c-candy boys ♪
♪ Lemonade l-l-lemonade ♪
- [Arthur] Sophie's debut album,
the "Oil of Every Pearl's Un-Insides"
received high acclaim for its
continued evolution of sound.
The album was even nominated
for the best dance/electronic
album at the 2019 Grammy's.
Sophie tragically passed
away January, 2021
at the age of 34 after an accidental fall.
After the news of the accident
reached the hyperpop community,
many artists came together on
social media to mourn the loss
of one of their greatest influences.
- [Linda] While hyperpop was brewing,
Charli XCX was already
a rising pop figure,
looking to evolve her sound.
Charli rose to prominence at
the UK warehouse rave scene
and admired artists such
as Justice and Uffie.
Now she wanted to create music
that reflected her roots.
After penning an email to
producer Sophie in 2015,
they began collaborating on
her 2016 EP, "Vroom Vroom".
♪ Let me ride let me ride ♪
♪ All my life I've been
waitin' for a good time ♪
- When Charli first
released "Vroom Vroom",
it was met with a lot of confusion
and critics were quick to write it off.
In 2016, A.G. Cook became
Charli's creative director.
He would go on to produce
her next four projects.
Number One Angel,
Pop 2,
Charli and How I'm Feeling Now.
Pop 2 is considered by many to
be the blueprint of hyperpop
and everything that PC music
has been leading up to.
♪ Can you unlock it ♪
♪ Caught in the liplock when we pitstop ♪
- Hyperpop hit mainstream awareness
with the creation of the
hyperpop Spotify playlist
in August, 2019.
- [Linda] Lizzy Szabo,
the playlist main curator,
created the playlist in response
to the unexpected success
of a 100 Gecs' debut album, 1,000 Gecs.
- They had tested some
of the group's songs
on different playlists,
but felt their unique sound
needed its own place
and so came the birth of
the hyperpop playlist.
- If it wasn't for Spotify playlist
and the articles that were
coming out at the time,
the community of friends
and the people I was making music with,
slowly bit by bit, started
getting recognition
by one artist, by another,
by another, by another.
They generally started to build
a following for themselves,
but a lot of people used
hyperpop, not even used,
but a lot of people were...
That label really was thrown on us.
We really was just making
music like SoundCloud kids
making music from our bedrooms.
And then afterwards it grew
and bloomed into
something even bigger than
I think any of us ever expected it to be.
- [Linda] The playlist was a hit
and now has over 240,000 subscribers,
making it one of the most
popular on the entire platform.
A few months later, controversy struck
when A. G. Cook did his own
takeover of the playlist
and added different artists,
including Iggy Azalea,
Madonna, Vince Staples,
Nicki Minaj and Kate Bush,
all of whom don't exactly fit
under the hyperpop umbrella.
Not only did his choices bump
many smaller artists of color
off the playlist,
but it caused lots of confusion
around what exactly constitutes hyperpop.
Cook later defended his
choices in a Twitter statement,
and claimed he didn't know these artists
would be taken off of the playlist.
He then issued a revised
version of the playlist
that included more underground acts.
To many, hyperpop is
more than just a genre
but an online centered
community and movement.
- Yeah, I think hyperpop is sort of like
an umbrella for a ton
of smaller communities.
Like I feel like I'm part of like several
very like niche, small
communities that all kind of exist
under the world of hyperpop.
- [Arthur] In 2021, the
term Digicore came about
after emerging from SoundCloud.
Unlike its ancestors of PC
music, which is mainly white,
Digicore is made up of
mostly queer people of color.
- Hyperpop kind of got thrown on us when
a lot of the more major
artists and bigger companies
started to see
just everything like
start to shoot up.
- This whole world...
... of Soundcloud musicians,
right.
- [Midwxst] Yeah,
it was starting to be discovered.
But Digicore is the one that
a lot of people went with
because it was like, a lot
of songs that people make
in the hyperpop scene aren't pop at all.
It's hyper-electronic.
- [Arthur] Yeah.
- It's hyper-ambient,
it's hyper drum and bass.
- [Arthur] Yeah.
- It's never really pop.
(upbeat music)
- [Arthur] When I think of hyperpop,
I'm thinking of a lot of stuff
going on at the same time,
I'm thinking of simple melodies
occurring at the same time.
(upbeat hyperpop music)
- Just listening to hyperpop,
I could see all of the sub genres
that go under that huge
umbrella of hyperpop.
- I don't know if this is gonna be right,
but I feel like it's not wrong, you know?
- I think that's like the
whole hyperpop attitude
is just like,
we're not really aiming for what's right,
we're just aiming for what feels good.
There ain't no wrong answers.
- Yeah.
- That's what really
I'm discovering is like,
there are no wrong answers.
(electronic beat)
- There, go.
(upbeat music)
- What you did with the vocals...
- The sentiment behind
the lyrics too like...
(Arthur singing)
- Yeah.
- It's like it has some spice to it.
♪ Got me thinking I don't
like your attitude ♪
- I was admiring the way that
these hyperpop artists are
using like production as a
way to express their emotions
when they're songwriting.
Like I just thought it was really cool.
♪ Got me thinking I don't
like your attitude ♪
(upbeat music)
♪ Got me thinking I don't
like your attitude ♪
- That's crazy.
One more thing,
we want to invite you to
take the PBS Digital Studios,
annual audience survey.
It helps us a lot if Sound
Field fans participate,
you even get to vote
on potential new shows.
There's a link in the description below
and if you have a few minutes,
we will love your input.
Thanks.